hello everyone and welcome to the 2018
World Chess Championship match between
Magnus Carlsen and Fabiana Caruana
as the 12 games of the classical time
format have been drawn now we enter the
rapid tiebreaks we will be having four
games of the rapid time format that's 25
minutes per player plus nine seconds
increment and if that also section of
the match is drawn then we enter the ten
games of blitz basically five mini
matches but we're gonna get into that if
we see that so this is Game one Coulson
has the white pieces without further ado
let's check out how this game went as I
will be trying to show you the games as
they are being played so for the first
move Carson opens with c4 and in their
previous encounter so they've played six
rapid games four of the games were
decisive two wins cross and two wins
Caruana and two of the games were drawn
and also you can see the ratings are a
bit different now Magnus cross and 2880
Fabiano core 127 89 so quite a
difference you know in rating in the
rapid section even though their mutual
Encounters are tied see for the English
opening is on the board we have E 5
Knight to c3 Knight to f6 and already we
have g3 cross and deviates with this
line that was no doubt to prepared
specifically for the rapid section but
should be for him now comes he for
Michaelson and Kerwin are simply castles
this is not an offer to actually capture
the pawn it you'll simply just give up
your Bishop pair after captures Knight
captures only for Queen e2 now black has
to defend the night somehow if he tries
with the d5 captures captures you will
go Bishop to g2 and already black will
have a quite an uncomfortable position
you will have to defend it let's say f5
and now okay not d3 obviously
immediately because Queen to a5 will go
after a c3 pawn but first you defend it
and now already black has given y too
much so Carlsen goes Caruana castles
here we have Knight G to e2 and already
this is move 5 we have a position that
was never before played in in any
championship or at least not to my
knowledge as I wasn't able to find it in
the database so Carson wants if this
Bishop captures the knight on
III Carson is preparing to challenge it
to capture with the night we have six
it's by Caruana
bishop dg2 crossing fiend Karros the
bishop also prepares the castle a six
and a cross and dust castle now we have
b5 Caruana challenges causing c4 pawn
and now Carson goes d4 challenging
kuranes ePHI pawn and you don't want to
capture here you're just gonna improve
wise development so Khurana simply
defends his ePHI pawn we have a three
cross and challenges the bishop the
bishop captures on c3 Knight captures on
c3 and now B captors on c4 finally
Caruana grabs the pawn he is now up upon
but he has a CC pawn but more
importantly it's not that he's up upon
de but this c4 pawn does a very nice job
of controlling the b3 and the D three
squares cross and goes D captures on e5
we have D captures on e5 and now comes
Knight to a4 a very nice move
anticipating caranas Knight d7 where he
will control the c5 the b6 and c5 square
but if that happens cross and can go
Bishop to d3 and also keep an eye over
those squares with both night ended the
bishop would have Bishop to e6 capturing
the Queen will only improve Carlson's
control over the D file so Bishop to e6
now defending the D extra pawn on c4 and
here Carlsen could go Knights to c5
immediately which a lot of people
thought that he would do now night night
b7 is no longer a possibility as the
knife captures and he's on e6 comes oh
and then black would have doubled C pawn
and also a double e pawn so most likely
here instead of developing the knight
something like Queen Queen to e7 would
have to be played Knight captures Queen
captures and then Bishop to e3 and that
the game goes on but Crossin as this is
a rapid game he likes his chances in a
queenless game Queen captures rook
captures and now comes the Bishop to e3
with a very nice control of these two
squares and The Crossings plan is at
some point to put one of the rooks and
c1 move this rook away from f1 play
Bishop to f1 to control to try and pick
up the c4 pawn that way 9b d7
now we have F 3 and now d4 pawn is
given additional protection so now the
boat the rook and the bishop cannot move
rook 88 going after Carlson's B to pawn
so the knight is not pretty much stuck
on a for defending it
rook 8 to c1 and now comes Luke to b3
like we said this is a very nice spawn
here controlling the b3 and III squares
now qur'anic a needle dub a Peter double
rooks on the B file would look D to be
eight or perhaps this rook can come to
d3 at some point we have looked F to e 1
by Carlson this rook came at the b3 with
an attack against the e3 bishops across
and us have to protect it and now comes
Knights the e8 Khurana wants to play
this Knight to d6 to be able to protect
the pawn with the knife from d6 also a
possibility was this Knight rook DB 8
and then after Carlson attacks the c4
pawn c3 actually and now after rook
captures rook captures pawn captures
rook b3 attacking the a3 pawn and now
after rook to a1 white would the
material advantage would equalize them
there would be no material advantage but
to White's rook would be somewhat
awkwardly passively placed on a want but
okay
after this rook F to e 1 we have Knights
to e8 by Caruana now comes in Bishop to
f1 attacking the the c4 pawn and the
Knight to d6 now the ponies at defender
twice and here Carlsen goes the rook C
to D 1 he decides okay I'm not gonna
attack that your c4 pawn I'm rather
gonna attack your defender of the c4
pawn and here Carolyn I really started
spending his time and he decided to play
nice to b5 which kind of loses material
night the b7 I did make some more sense
as here he controls the c5 square twice
but he's he decided to go for a
different light he played Knights the b5
and cousin simply went Knights the c5
now the rook and b3 is under attack you
can't really move it you have to capture
the night or you can capture the pawn
with the rope which is what Caruana
played Rock chapter son b2 was played
and here Carson was a some 14 minutes
and something on the clock or mana was
some 10 minutes on the clock and Carlsen
decided to go for Knight captures on e6
which is definitely the way to go F
captors on e6 and here it seems like
white is immediately winning after
Bishop to g5 and
because you have to move the rook and
after we move the rook you lose the
night but it's not really all that clear
here after nights the d4 if you capture
the rook Bishop capture Sun d8 you would
get Knight captures on f3 check King
moves when the rook captures on h2 with
checkmate so the problem is after this
Knights the d4 move you would not be
able to capture the bishop you would
rather have to play rook capture Sundy
for an hour after pawn captures Bishop
captures and e8 you would play Knight to
e5 to defend your c4 pawn and now
Caruana is very dangerous past bonds
will be stronger than Carlson's extra
bishop
so Crossland decides to go for Bishop
captures on c4 and here we have Knights
to d4 finally this was an interesting
decision because if King to f7 is played
then okay you are protecting d6 pawn but
now there's a whole set of other
problems now Bishop captures on b5
eliminates that move Knights the d4 and
now after this Bishop is recaptured you
will get Bishop to g5 and now you will
either move the rook really and face
rook captures on d7 or you will defend
it and then you will simply be down the
exchange and suffer until you lose the
game
so after Bishop captures on c4 Knight
9:34 was played and now comes Bishop
captures on d4 he captures on d4 and
here Carlsen even though it's a rapid
game it took him nine minutes and 23
seconds to come up with his next move
because it's a really a huge decision do
you want to capture on e6 with check and
only then capture on d4 or do you want
to first capture rugby for allow King to
f7 and then see what happens if rook
captures immediately and then King to f7
it seems like rook to d1 is once again
crushing but black will still have this
nice to e5 move and then after you
capture it tonight captures only three
comes with the check if King knows rook
captures on h2 will be checkmate and if
you go to f1 you will simply run into a
perpetual check King G one out of three
King f1 it wherever go either if you go
looking GE won again tonight of three
checking has to move and here you will
have a perpetual or a draw by perpetual
so Carlsen decides to go for a different
line Bishop captures on e6 immediately
we have came to f8 and now look captures
on d4
keep the e7 Khurana decides to go for an
endgame where he is down a rook but it's
not all that all that terrible Luke
captures rook captures Bishop captures
King captures and now comes roof to d1
check here across and had some three
minutes on the clock in Khurana had
eight minutes on the clock we have King
to e6 getting out of check and now comes
F for Carlson now and now is up upon he
has excellent control of the center but
one of the problems is that karana
controls the second rank and Crossan can
never get his King into the game we have
c5 here Caruana starts pushing his own
path pawn as you really have to be
active we have worked the d5 and here
comes rook to c2 probably a better idea
for korra wanna was c for allowing
carson and caused him to put his rogue
behind the past pawn and only then after
rook the sea to black would definitely
want to attack this rook after e5 white
will not allow it but still it will be
very hard for crossing to improve
because the rook will not allow the king
anywhere karana
decided to go for a different line he
played immediately rook to c2 defending
not allowing this rook to come to c5 now
and now we have h4 if Crossan starts
with f5 immediately then king to have
six will make it somewhat difficult to
start pushing any of the points so first
before playing f5 check car across and
wants to prepare it
so after looks to see - we have h4 and
now comes c4 we have f5 which check King
to f6 and now comes rock the c5 if you
start immediately with g4 then Caruana
has this look to e2 idea the pawn is now
under attack and now after g5 check King
to f7 now comes a five as you have to
protect this pawn c3 and now after a six
check and King to e8 there's really no
more way to push your pawns and c2 c1 is
also coming so black would have enough
resources to draw this game so after
King to have six we have looked a c5 by
cross and putting his rook behind a
passed pawn h5 Caruana prevents Carlson
from pushing g4 but now we have king to
f1 Carlson wants to attack kuranes rook
with his King and here
either you're gonna play C 3 and the
constant will keep bringing his King
over to your rook Khurana decides to go
for a different plan
look the C 3 he attacks the g3 pawn and
also D a trip on Carson of course
protects the g3 pawn but now with this
move
Corona allowed Carson to enter the
second rank with his King we have rope
captures on a tree rook captures on c4
and now King to e5 rook to rook to c7
going after the g7 pawn and allowing
cousin Khurana to capture his e4 pawn
king captures and now rook captures on
g7 who seems like a pretty hot mattock
move but here actually looked to it to
check forces cousin to go back with the
king and only then will Carr wanna
capture with his King to f5 and here
perhaps he would have greater chances of
defending across and plays the absolute
best move rook to e7 check forces
Caruana to now capture with the king
moving his King back we have King
captors on f5 and only now king capture
second g7 and now Khurana has no ways of
pushing cousins King back and caranas
own king is a bit further back from the
action here we have came to f6 and by
this point in the game Carson was down
to 210 seconds we have looked the g5
going after the h5 pawn of course a5 and
now real captures on h5
so now Carson has to postpones on the
kingside quran has a passed pawn on the
Queen side we have a for rook to a5 and
now look to a1 Khurana wants to push
this pawn as far as close to the a1
square as possible
King to f3 we have a three
Luke to a6 chip King g7 and now comes
King to g2 look to a to check King now
goes back to h3 look to a-1 and here
cross and pushes h5 it's very
interesting but if he wants King G for
this appears to be a draw because now
after a 2 and you start pushing the pawn
h5 King h7 h6
we have King to h8 now Luke a7 preparing
to pull the pawn king g8 whenever you
try to bring your king closer
for example King g5 black will always
have this rook to g1 move where he will
either threaten to capture this pawn or
or
the Queen now you will have the capture
and after this captures this is now a
drawn endgame so Carson plays the
correct idea not King g4 but first h5
came to h7 we have king we have g4 now
King to g7 and now King to h4 a2 we have
King to g5 and now comes King to f7 we
have h6 look to be one and now Carlsen
can grab this pawn immediately but he
doesn't want to allow rook the c5 so
first he pushes the black king further
back we have looked to a7 check King g8
and only now rook captures an a to Luke
the b5 check we have King to be a king
to g6 rook to b6 check King to h5 and
now any further checks are pretty much
pointless as then g5 is coming and with
two points against the zero points of
course this is a clearly winning endgame
for white so here for the first time in
this world chess championship match it's
not in classical time for them but
rather in the first game of the rapid
time format
Fabiana Caruana resigned the game so
yeah that's the game one I do hope you
enjoyed it
let's see what happens in game 2 as I'm
pretty much trying to you know share
these games with you as they are being
played I would like to thank Donna
Clarissa Joshua would Zachary heavens
Hong Mugen and Salvatorian brunette for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous previous videos
here thank you for watching and I will
see you soon with the game to all the
rapid Khurana has the white pieces next
see you soon